on prend pas nos petites chansons dans
les guinguettes on entend pas nos
refrains sur les boulevards on voit pas
nos noms partout dans les gazettes on
met pas nos cœurs à nuus dans les
canards on a tellement peur d'attraper
la grosse tête que pour s'en apercevoir
on va tous bientôt s'acheter une petite
casquette et l'essayer tous les
soirs on n apprend pas nos chansons dans
les écoles on mettra pas nosins dans les
musées les paroles on les écrit pour
qu'ell s'envolent les qu'on les écrit
pour
[Musique]
s'amuser on a beau graé nos BO dans la
résine et passé sous des sair et des
diamants on a beau changer les plateaux
en platine on a beau changer les
chansons en
[Musique]
argent on prend pas nos petites chansons
dans les guinguettes onentend pas nos
refin dans les couloirs on est ni des
cabotins ni des poètes on a simplement
le cœur à s'émouvoir on a tellement peur
d'attraper des vertiges en tournant sur
des faonau qu'on va tous apprendre à
faire de la voltige pour ne pas tomber
d' et comment on peut pas nous mettre
une étiquette on nous met dans les
divers et les bizarres on prend pas nos
petites chansons dans les guinguettes
onentend pas ns sur les
Bou
on napend pas nos chansons dans les
écoles on mettra pas nos refins dans les
musées les paroles on les écrit pour qu'
sen les musi on les écrit pour
[Musique]
s'amuser onend pas nos petites chansons
dans les guinguettes on nentend pas nos
refrains sur les boulevards mais le soir
dans nos maisons quand tout s'arrête
reste encore un peu d'amour reste encore
un peu
d'espoir rest enc un peu d'amour dans
[Musique]
guitares reste encore un peu d'amour
dans nos
[Musique]
guitares
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
reste encore un peu d'amour dans nos
guitares